[Musique]
serge gainsbourg cette semaine vous
allez être l'homme de la télévision
celui que certains adultes parce que le
personnage est provocateur et branché
dont le moins qu'on puisse dire de vous
c'est que vous êtes un homme riche en
talent pas au sens pécunier que d'autres
exècre parce que provocateur et amoral
comment se fait-il que vous ne composé
presque exclusivement que pour des
femmes
expliquez-moi le texte de sucettes c'est
plus la même c'est une petite fille qui
aime bien mais si cette cale achète au
drugstore pour quelques pennies un bon
avantage d'être fraîche et rosset et
fils est tous d'accord c'est pas trop
[Musique]
le 6
sérieux
hulu dans la
je
et
thomas
[Musique]
s'appelle la décadence onyx d'em sport
comme dans n'importe quelle d'or
souvenez ce qui se passait 1,45 1,50
est-ce que c'est véritablement une
nouvelle danse ou un gag d'ascenseur de
vieilles peaux qui se fourvoyer l'ajout
[Musique]
semble être un partenaire dans le tour
il pensait pas qu'on va vers le chaos et
de tels exemples pour la jeunesse n'ont
absolument pas et j'espère bien on va
danser sur les airs puis sa mise sur le
marché de toute une des filles est comme
qui veut même pas d inceste
on n'a pas voulu montrer les parties
génitales et cède à wadia phoque
oui alors je vais vous traduire non non
non non non icwa regrets chardy oui
l'iphone
oui vous l'essayez il dit que vous êtes
très joli non non non non non c'était
non non j'ai pas dis aux deux il a dit
ça mais ça lui arrive devant rien je
peux pas vous traduire ce qu'il a dit
je vends de vente il a dit j'aimerais
bien vous auriez le pleure pas du tout
j'ai dit jean réduire apaisé mais il a
vite un jésuite rota torrent pas si
grave non il dit il est normal vous
imaginez quand les juges j'ai peur que
notre public ne vous entendent pas sur
l'amour passion est rousse un adepte des
plaisirs solitaires tout à fait ou
absolument pas je regagnais le pays la
france et ben voilà il fallait le dire
que celui qui m'attaque je crois je me
casse les dents luke young dont les
blaireaux la suis assoupi
et qui est redonné un appareil est
encensé disent qu'elles n'avaient rien
aux mineurs une chanson mekhissi à leurs
abonnés a annoncé béart qui te parle
oui mais j'ai bien en quoi est ce que
ces mineurs une chanson sur quoi
dégonfler
je n'éprouve situera que la peinture n'a
pas besoin d'initiation mécabourg la
chanson et je vous demanderai de la
chanter avec moi
de la pap y y et le jour de gloire est
ta vie des carriers me et par pierre
bruttin et j'ai toujours de faire ses
moyens de refroidir que vous traitez vos
moselle de façon très douce et très
souple mais regardez comment on va
traiter mais ça n'a aucun rapport
dans ce monde il provoque donc vous
procure autant d'animosité pourquoi des
siens dans ce disque c'est donc c'est un
peu scriptum de strasbourg je pense que
cette interview restera dans la mémoire
d'henri chapier je trouve que je suis
touché et je suis dit je suis là j'ai
toujours rien toujours un coût
[Musique]